all right uh
we made it to the final session uh and
if in the final session we have two very
exciting talks the first one is by Luana
Ruiz who will tell us about recent
advancements in graph neural networks
and its connection to graph forms it's
good thank you thank you very much for
the uh invitation from the organizers so
today I'm going to speak about
um some research that I did on machine
learning on large scale graphs um using
graphones I'll focus on graph neural
networks so this will be somewhat
related to Morgan's talk on Wednesday
um but here instead of embedding refs
and graph data onto clearance spaces
here we're going to look at how we can
translate the convolution operation to
to the graph domain
so to motivate my talk there are two
preliminary questions that I have to
answer and the first one is the why and
the second one is the help so the the
why is which is why do we care about um
machine learning and large-scale graphs
um the answer to that question is
relatively simple
and it's the need that it is that the
need to process information on very
large graphs arises in a wide range of
applications so here on the slide I
guess I give two examples on the left uh
we have an example of a of a product
similarity graph where the nodes
represent products the edges represent
product similarities we assume that we
have some data on top of the notes of
this wrap so some ratings that a user or
consumer has given to some of these
products and we want to leverage these
uh these ratings these existing ratings
and the graph structure to fill in
missing ratings for for recommendation
the graph on the right I don't know if
you can see it very well here but if not
you can see it on the on the televisions
um It's A Wrap of robots or agents and
the idea here is that we want to control
these agents in a distributed manner to
achieve a common task in this case uh
this represents a consensus task where
we want them to coordinate their
velocities while avoiding collisions but
the catch is that the communications are
limited by proximity so as to reduce
interference and so uh control policy
must respect the availability of
information that is kind of determined
by this by this graph
both of these problems are examples of
problems where machine learning has
achieved you know very good results
um sometimes even better than than other
other existing Solutions and they're
also examples of problems that become
more interesting as these graphs grow
right so as the number of products is
for example in the order of a few
thousand the number of robots in the
order of a couple hundred but these
large number of note regimes are also
when these problems are learning uh
Solutions right like learning machine
learning models or these problems
becomes harder
so on to the second question which is
how do we do machine learning on large
scale graphs the answer to that question
is also relatively simple and it is by
using neural metrics right so there's uh
uh in the last 10 to 15 years there's an
ample amount of empirical and
theoretical evidence to support using
neural networks for machine learning but
the issue here is that standard neural
networks by which I mean fully connected
neural networks are not scalable right
because there are no number of
parameters would increase with the with
the graph size and so we need to use
convolutional neural networks or cnns
that we know that are known to scale
well for large time signals and large
images
future with cnns though is that they
only operate on regular grid-like data
such as the data on the left while we
want them to in our case operate on data
that looks more like this graph here on
the right
and so what we need is a way to extend
convolutions and cnns to the graph
domain right and this has been done
in this paper and a bunch of papers but
in particular in this paper from from
2017 which was the first one to kind of
formalize it by extending convolutions
to graph convolutions and convolutionary
networks to graph convolutional neural
networks and here I'm going to refer to
them as graph neural networks or gnns
for short
and I should say that you know this this
idea works so it's extending
convolutions and cnns to to graphs has
been shown to work it works well at a
moderate scale but we have those um we
have a harder time training these models
as the graph size increases
so in this setting in my research there
are two kind of fundamental
um kind of problems that I'm interested
in the first one is that we have
empirically observed that GNN scale well
and when we apply them for example in
those two problems but we don't know why
they do so I want to understand why they
scale
and the second one is knowing that gnns
do well on these moderate scale graphs
can we then leverage their success at a
on these moderate size graphs to create
success at a at a large scale
and to answer both of these questions I
think it's worth looking at CNN's which
are known to scol for for images and and
time signals right
so one reason why cnns and convolutions
scale well is because uh discrete time
signals and discrete images have
well-defined continuous time signal and
image limits right so for example here
on the slide I have the same scene
sample that different resolutions and we
can clearly see that this is a
convergent sequence right like
especially when we look at these two
things here they're almost like
indiscernible to to the human eye
what the existence of this limit implies
in practice is that the intrinsic
dimensionality of the problem is
typically smaller than the dimensions of
the image itself of the data itself
right
but a more subtle observation from like
signal processing theory is that uh the
cnns and convolution scale well on this
type of data because discrete time and
two-dimensional convolutions converge to
continuous time and continuous
two-dimensional uh convolutions right
and so this fact is what provides the
answers to the those two questions that
I asked in the case of graphs in the
case of images for example
foreign
definition of intrinsic dimensionality
or is it just something you sort of um
so if you think of a matrix the rank of
the Matrix right so so here like the
principal components for example of this
image like you have a few a small number
of principal components right that would
allow you to classify this for example
can you think that the continuous ones
have less than the
um what I'm saying is that they all kind
of have the same number of principal
components because you don't need to
sample this with a very like high
resolution to C to be able to tell okay
this is a like an answer
the name of this Animal by the way thank
you
um okay
so you know the the existence of this
limit
um is what answers those two questions
right the first one so we know that we
scale well to large images because the
intrinsic dimensionality of the problem
is less than the size of the image and
we can leverage the success of gnn's on
moderate size images uh to create
success in large scale image data
because training with small images is
sufficient for example sci-fi 10 images
which I think are the ones that are used
to train for example object recognition
image classification models are 32 by 32
and models trained with them work pretty
well
foreign
so coming back to graphs it turns out
graphs as we have been hearing here in
this program and in this Workshop graphs
also have limit objects that effectively
limit their dimensionality right one
such limit object is the graphome
and uh I'm not going to spend too much
time talking about Grifols we're going
to come back to them later but what I
wanted to show here on the slide is that
you know in a sequence of graphs
converging to a graphoma you can clearly
see that the overall structure of these
graphs converges to the overall uh
structure of the gruffal right and so
this is a this is good news because we
we also have a clear notion of limit
however the existence of this limit
doesn't necessarily imply that graph
convolutions converge to a limit object
on on the graphone right and the reason
for that is because these graphs don't
have the euclidean structure that time
and image signals have in the limit
convergence of convolutions and
euclidean domains is actually related to
sampling which is regular it depends on
Geometry and so it won't translate as
easily to graphs and so convergence of
graph convolutions and graph neural
networks to their corresponding limit
objects on the graph phone uh which I'm
going to call graph phone convolutions
and graphical neural networks our Act is
actually a result that needs to be to be
established
so in this uh work we have uh
established this result by showing that
um that uh graph convolutions and graph
neural networks converge to graph from
convolutions and graphone neural
networks and then this is what kind of
provides the answer to that first
question right we scale well in practice
and scale well in practice because they
have well-defined limits on on reference
and so this is like an asymptotic
convergence results that I'm going to
discuss later on in this talk and then
we also developed kind of the finite
sample version of this result which
essentially kind of like upper bounds
the difference between the outputs of
the GNN on like one graph in the
sequence converging geographer and
another graph and like you can see that
as you know like an approximation bound
but you could also interpret that to
mean transferability right because that
if that error is small if you can bound
it by a small quantity this means that
we can take a GNN train it on a graph
transfer it to another larger graph make
a small error you know that but but that
is still allowed in our specific
application and so this is a way in
which we can kind of use the success of
gnns on these moderate size graphs to
create success at a large scale
and indeed this transferability of uh
convolutions and rough neural networks
is useful and it's applicable in
practice and in particular we observe it
in those two applications that I
mentioned um earlier on so here for
example we have that product
recommendation setting right here the
nodes are our movies uh and what we want
to do is we want to leverage this graph
this collaborative filtering graph to
predict uh uh product ratings right so
transferability means that we can train
our GNN model on this smaller graph and
then transfer it to this larger graph
and so uh what I'm plotting here on this
uh plot here on the right is on the
excesses excess axis uh the size of the
of the training graph which is that
smaller graph
the the the kind of like the target
graph always has for a thousand uh nodes
and what I plot here is uh the
difference between the normalized mean
square error of prediction uh achieved
by the same GNN on the training graph
and on the target graph and here we see
that all of these models the graph
filter which is kind of like a linear
GNN and these two dnns that I'm going to
get more into the detail of their
differences later on they kind of this
error decreases as we increase the size
of the trading graph right another
interesting thing is that for a fixed
size the training graph the gnns that
appear to be more transferable than the
graph filter and the kind of like the
theoretical results that I'm going to
talk about later on
um seem to provide a possible
explanation provide that is
and here again coming back to that
flocking our distributed control example
now the idea is that we want to train uh
gnm-based control policy on a smaller
graph we train it by kind of
um optimizing a cost which is a
weighting of velocity differences in
Collision penalties
and then we executed on the larger graph
which always has 100 agents again the
size of the training graph is on the
x-axis and here we're plotting the
difference between the cost achieved by
the same GNN on the training in the
Target graph and You observe that kind
of same behavior
um
the robot flocking example what is the
graph I mean is it are they interacting
are certain pairs interacting regardless
of where they are or are they
interacting with their yeah so it's a
it's a geometric map so there's a
communication radius and so uh they're
communicating within their communication
radius
let's see okay
where he may have meant it but I'm not
sure isn't that a dynamically changing
graph as a as the skies fly I mean
they're not standing there right yeah
they're moving yeah it is dynamically
changing but but you didn't talk about
dynamically changing graph neural
networks I didn't I didn't talk about
that but it's not that different I mean
you're just kind of add communication
delays
um so so effectively you have many
graphs like the graph at time zero one
two and so on or how to reduce it yes
yes you have many graphs uh I see I can
I can kind of point to it in like the
expression of the convolution where the
graph would change
but it's a good point
okay so let me be in the technical
discussion by defining graph
convolutions and to Define uh graph
convolutions it's helpful to look at how
we might represent
um discrete time our image convolutions
as convolutions on graphs
so if we for example want to describe a
time convolution
um as a graph convolution first thing
that we do is we describe time with the
directed line graph
we write the adjacency Matrix of this
graph that I'm going to represent as s
and then we can write a time convolution
on this graph as a polynomial on The
adjacency Matrix
so just the one on the on the slide
where each each term of this polynomial
can interpret it as like a shift in time
similarly if we want to now represent an
image convolution as a convolution on
the graph we may write the
two-dimensional space the quadian space
is a as this grid graph
uh write the adjacency Matrix as of this
graph and same thing write the image or
two-dimensional convolution as a
polynomial The adjacency Matrix of this
graph
are you so is there some sort of
aggregation at vertices where it's step
K you get information of Hindu vertices
up to distance K from you I'm just
trying to understand what this is
convolution of adjacency matrices is
yeah that's the idea so when you kind of
have this um like the case power of the
adjacency Matrix you're kind of
aggregating information from Neighbors
that are k-hops away okay thank you
but these are all weighted by this these
uh coefficients h0 H1 H2 we tried the
kind of coefficients of your filter your
convolutional filter I see okay okay
thanks
thanks
so yes
so is there a
non-linearity coming there is okay uh
yeah surprisingly much later but there's
here I'm kind of talking about the graph
collusional filter which is kind of the
linear model or the building blocks of
the GMA
um
K is your number of filter coefficients
you just choose K the idea here is that
you know your graph has size n typically
K can be much smaller than n and that's
kind of like the benefit of these
convolutional parametrizations because
the number of parameters is independent
of the graph size
okay so from those two examples it
shouldn't be too hard to see that if you
just have like an arbitrary graph
arbitrary data on top of this graph
these These are the signal x uh you can
write the graph convolution as a
polynomial on The adjacency Matrix of
this graph right where now the
each term of the polynomial represents a
a graph shift
okay so this is the definition of of
graph convolutions and as I'll explain
later on graph convolutions are kind of
like the main building block of gnns and
so if we want to establish Converse
convergence of gnns to graphominance uh
we need to analyze the convergence of
graph convolutions to graphene
convolutions so let me Define graphene
convolutions but before I do that um let
me kind of give a formal definition of
reference
um so the gravel is this bounded
symmetric measurable function mapping
points of the unit squared to the unit
interval uh
I I like to think of it when I first
learned about acrophones that I like to
think of it as this weighted symmetric
graph with an uncountable number of
nodes
and uh I'm interested in the in two
interpretations of graph phones right so
the first one is the limit of a sequence
of graphs in the sense that the these
motifs and local structures and and
therefore Global structures converge and
also as with as in the interpretation of
graphones as generative models of graph
families by sampling edges for newly
with probability wiuj
and I don't need to give these um silly
examples to the art for this audience
but you know here I just have an example
in the name of the journey uh graph a
sequence of graphs converting internet
does Randy Griffo and you could also
think of sampling these graphs from this
graph phone and here a more interesting
example which is of uh to community SPM
um graph sequence and riffle
okay
so
um
I've defined graph convolutions and
graph phones now how would we Define a
graphone convolution right so remember
that we defined the graph convolution as
a polynomial on The adjacency Matrix of
the graph right and uh the the idea here
is that this graph convolution is
actually parametrized better by an
operator which is a very simple operator
which is just the matrix multiplication
by the The Matrix S right you you have a
kind of like a series of of
multiplications by S to obtain kind of
like this this consecutive Powers
um and this is actually something that
in graph signal processing we call the
graph shift operator and so since we
parametrize graph convolutions by the
graph shift operator I'm going to do the
same thing for in the case of the of the
graphene convolution so let me Define
the reference shift operator
so to define the the graphone shift
operator I mean simplistically we can
think of the graphome as kind of like
this uh infinite dimensional Matrix
right and so
we could think of the graphone shift
operators like this uh simplistically uh
Matrix Vector multiplication and
infinite Dimensions which is just the
integral of uh
W Times X right so the integral linear
operator with with kernel w
so you may have missed it but did you
define how do you initialize X's
so access is like your data on top of
the nodes of your graph so this is
something you assume that you have and
do you need some
some conditions
is your ratings right okay the ratings
uh of your products for example
okay so with this verification of the
graph phone shift operator out of the
way then we just Define the graphone
convolution analogously to the graph
convolution right as this kind of
polynomial on the graph form shift
operator of the of the graph
foreign
so so far uh what I have told you is
that we can represent graph convolutions
and also graphone convolutions as it's
shift in some operations on the graph
and graphene domain respectively but
what I haven't told you is that we can
also represent same as we can do with
like time convolutions right we can
represent uh these graphing graphene
convolutions in the graph in reform
frequency or spectral domain
respectively
so
um this might seem like a mod detour but
I I'm gonna take this detour because
later on it's going to be easier to
understand the convergence of graph
convolutions and gnns in the spectral
domain so let me talk a little bit about
about
um the frequency representation of these
of these graphing graphical convolutions
so um
it's just something to clarify when we
in the cnns we usually have a weight
Matrix which hasn't appeared here
anywhere is that something that you're
going to introduce later or is that not
the thing so the the weight Matrix is
essential it's just that here I'm not
concerning that I have multiple channels
I'm just considering one channel and so
that weight Matrix would be these
coefficients h k okay okay
so um so here we're considering
symmetric graphs right so they had made
an eigen decomposition uh and in graph
signal processing what we do is we
interpret the eigenvalues of the
adjacency Matrix as graph frequencies
and then the corresponding eigenvectors
is the corresponding graph oscillation
modes
and so kind of building on this uh this
interpretation we also Define a
graphical gear transform which is just a
projection of your data X onto the eigen
basis of your graph of JCC Matrix right
and so what this very simple theorem
here is saying is that if you have a
graph convolutional filter with
coefficients h k
input signal xn and output signal YN the
graphful here transforms of these
signals are related by this polynomial
expression here
which is just a polynomial with same
coefficients h k on the eigenvalues of
the graph
and this is just an eigenous composition
right it's a very simple result so it
shouldn't even warrant a theorem but the
reason why I wanted to highlight it as a
theorem here is because even though it's
simple it's it's interesting because it
shows us two things so the the first
thing that it shows is that the graph
convolution is a pointwise operator in
the spectral domain right because here
to kind of calculate the JS component of
the graph will be a transform this only
depends on the J Thug in value and the J
spectral component of x
and it also shows in a way it kind of
decouples the the graph convolutional
filter from the graph because it could
write the frequency representation of
these convolutional filter
um as this
polynomial and an arbitrary scalar
variable Lambda right
and this is yes go ahead
so uh I'd seen some similar
constructions before by using the
laplacian Matrix as opposed to The
adjacency Matrix is there any relevant
difference uh here like in the end
result
um so so I I come from a signal
processing background specifically graph
signal processing and we call these
matrices the graph shift operator and we
say okay this could be the adjacency it
could be the laplacian the graph
frequencies have or the graph eigen
values have different kind of
interpretations if you use the LaPlace
in here but here because I'm looking at
the graphene the graph one is kind of
like this large adjacency Matrix right
that's why I consider the adjacency
okay so this is easier to understand if
you look at this figure here where that
polynomial is represented by this red
curve
the graph eigenvalues are represented by
the green lines and so we see that kind
of like the graph only comes in when
we're trying to instantiate the
frequency response uh or evaluate the
frequency response of these
convolutional filter for a specific
graph right but
you know the you can write this curve
for basically the entire minus one
wanted
and as you will probably imagine uh from
what I kind of have been talking about
right now all of this kind of also holds
for graphone so we because the graphone
uh operator the graph phone shift
operator is a hibernation operator it
also admits an eigen decomposition we
can write the graph phone in this way in
terms of its eigenvalues and eigen
functions I'm assuming that it's uh
symmetric yes yes all right to 5 is then
going to be the same
the two fights
5G oh yeah it's supposed to be the same
sorry it's supposed to be the both
should be the bar pieces yeah yeah
they're both spies no yeah they look
different
um yeah so here we have the same uh
here we have the same interpretation so
the graphite the eigenvalues are
interpreted as graphical frequencies the
eigenfunctions as the corresponding
graphical oscillation modes we Define
the graph phone for here transforms by
taking these inner products right just
the projection onto the eigen basis and
here's same idea if we had a graphone
convolutional filters of coefficients h
k
the Garfunkel here transforms of the
output and input signals are related by
this polynomial which if I when two two
slides back is essentially the same
polynomial as we had in the case of the
graph so the important thing here is
that if the graphone convolution the
graph convolution have the same
coefficients h k the frequency response
of that filter is determined by the same
polynomial
um h of Lambda so this red curve the
only thing that changes is where we
instantiate this function right so at
the eigenvalues of the graph in green if
we're looking at the spectral response
of the graph convolution or at the
eigenvalues of the graph fall in blue if
we're looking at the frequency response
of the graphene
quick question
so this is very interesting I'm
wondering whether so for instance
imagine that there are two communities
in the graph on and actually in the
graphs the families and crafts and that
you tend to disagree about a rating or
an opinion with the people in the other
community
so in that case you don't necessarily
want to use the same coefficients for
all of your neighbors you want to First
do some block model like labeling of
who's in which community and then you
might want to learn ratings with a
negative coefficient on the edges that
jump from one Community to the other so
my understanding is that that type of
thing would not yet fit into this
framework would it because that's a good
point I mean at the at the borders of
the community
I don't know because like in the
communities themselves like in the inner
community
kind of consensus right I think the
problems would be the borders of the
communities maybe but it makes sense
that people at the borders would be
maybe
like less certain of their opinion right
so
um
if I understand correctly every every
once
so the question to me was why would it
not fit in this so so the
um
I mean let's say that we have a kind of
block model set up so everybody has an
equal chance of of having some uh some
connections to the other community so we
don't necessarily have cores and
peripheries within the two communities
so just the simple simple block model so
as I understand it you would give the
same coefficient to every one step in
the graph so you know one type of Kernel
would be average over your neighbor's
opinions and that's your opinion
but you could imagine that if I I'm not
sure how to anthropomorphize this but if
I know who is in my community and who is
in the other community
um I might actually put a negative
weight on the other people's uh opinion
so then it wouldn't fit in as I
understand it it wouldn't fit into this
framework because some you give a
different side tools that even possible
to actually implemented that would be a
clever way to to fix what I'm saying yes
but I I'm just saying that every every
Edge has the same coefficient every path
of length two has the same coefficient
and so on
I don't have the expression but if you
make cake large this is kind of like a
tailored
series approximation right like if you
make the HKS you're
the derivative right the K order so I
mean it's kind of like Christian was
saying like it wouldn't be very easy to
write but you could write it
people in the other community have fewer
common neighbors with me for instance
perhaps and then I could do this with a
quadratic term and okay all right
[Music]
so the picture seems to suggest
something in addition namely that
somehow I I mean maybe that's not what
you suggested but this picture almost
suggests I don't even care about the
graph I just once learned a polynomial
age of Lambda and now you choose your
favorite graph do the eigenvalue
decomposition
a value at h of Lambda and you get sort
of so the filter seems to be independent
of the graph so it almost is as if you
learned a universal filter which doesn't
depend on the graph at all at least I
can apply it to any graph
um yes you can apply to any graph but it
will have different
this filter would have very different
spectral uh representations on the
actual graphs because the graphs will
have very different eigenvalues right
and so like for one graph the the second
eigenvalue is here but then for the
other graph it might be here and so that
that has a huge difference right
so the eigenvectors matter right because
here we're only looking at the frequency
response
okay so before I
um explain to you why uh graph
convolutions converge geographical
convolutions I'll go ahead and tell you
that they do
and this is essentially what I'm saying
in this theorem right so what I'm saying
the serum is if I have a sequence of
graph signals GNX and converging to a
graphone w x and convolution graph
convolutions h of s n and agraphone
convolution th with the same
coefficients h of K
um the these graph convolutions of the
the the output signal of these graph
conclusions converges to the output of
the of the graphene convolution
however
um there is a kind of like a restriction
here and the Restriction is that the
spectral response of these convolutions
has to be Ellipsis function and this is
not a minor assumption right because
essentially with Ellipsis assumption
means is that we need this to be
relatively smooth
and what this means in practice then is
that the the our filter can't be super
discriminative right I mean there are
some limitations to to its
discriminability and it's this lipsticks
continuity assumption that is better
understood in the in the graph and graph
on spectral domain so let me go back to
to that
so the the they're they're kind of like
two facts associated with uh graphones
and and uh sequences of dense graphs
that help understand that um lipsticks
continuity assumption and their first
the fact that due to the graphone shift
operator being compact the graph form
eigenvalues accumulate at Lambda equal
to zero because the spectrum is
contained in -1 and the minus one one
interval and it's infinite dimensional
so the eigenvalues are accountable but
they accumulate um over there
and the second fact is that
um if you have a sequence of graphs
converging to a graphone
the eigenvalues of of these graphs
converge to the eigenvalues of of the
graph form
right but the the it's important to kind
of point out here that even though all
of these eigenvalues converge this
convergence is not uniform and it's not
uniform in the sense that in order to
show that for example eigenvalue is
close to zero are Epsilon close like the
graphic and values right are Epsilon
close to the corresponding graphology
value you need larger n so you need a
larger graph because these eigenvalues
are accumulated and so you risk kind of
mismatching graph and graphing that is
over there
so you know we saw that essentially the
graphene the graph convolution have the
same frequency or spectral response and
we also saw that the graph eigenvalues
converge to the graph of eigenvalues and
so
uh what we can expect then by looking at
this figure here is that the graph
convolution should converge to the
graphone convolution right
but the the problem here is like arises
precisely from those eigenvalues close
to zero because there convergence of
those spectral components is Complicated
by the fact that the eigenvalue
convergence is not uniform and so what
happens is that you know if you have a
filter that is pretty discriminative
here close to zero it might amplify
um
like corresponding graph and graphome
again values very differently because
they they're kind of there might be a
mismatch they might be like more matched
with a different uh graphing value of a
different index
and so
this kind of affects the convergence of
of of the spectral components and makes
it so that filter is attempting to
discriminate spectral components close
to Lambda equal to zero do not um
converge
but this can be solved by imposing that
Lipschitz continuity restriction right
and so if we have elliptic filter then
what we have is a filter that is almost
flat I mean with small ellipse is
constant right that is almost flat uh
here in this interval that I kind of
bound by a threshold minus C and C
and uh these filters what they do is
that even if there's a mismatch because
it's almost flat it kind of amplifies
the the entire projection onto the
second spaces very similarly and so it
removes that problem of of the mismatch
between the the projections right
but then like I mentioned before this
comes at the cost of spectral
discriminability because if these
filters are flat
in this region here then we can't have a
filter that can for example isolate one
of these spectral components right
okay so
um I have talked a lot about convergence
yeah
so when when we Define convergence of a
graph on to uh of a graph to a graph and
we have this cut metric where we
effectively
mod out also the labelings of the graph
but what do you do to your vector
when it converges to a function so so I
assume that that vector
or the step function kind of induced by
that Vector converges in L2 to the
reform signal
I see so you get just standard L2
conversion to the signal but you get
convergence of the Matrix to the graph
on
after relabeling yeah I also require all
two convergence well I mean the cut Norm
convergence for some sequence of
permutations implies L2 convergence
right of the induced Square phones
well whether it applies or not you you
assume L2 convergence let's say
I I assume convergence of the graphs
in Cut Norm
I see and that will imply convergence of
the Spectrum which is all you need yes
okay so now let me switch gears and talk
about
um transferability which is you know
convergence is kind of how we explain
why GN and scale well
um transferability will be how we kind
of try to leverage that good performance
of gnns on a modular size graphs to
to um do machine learning and large
scale graphs right so you know so far by
talking about convergence I talked about
in asymptotic results we saw that uh in
order to have convergence we we need
that lip shit's continuity assumption
um but what that analysis doesn't tell
us is like okay what's the effect of the
actual nipshits constant of the filter
on convergence on the rate of
convergence for example right in so in
order to to understand that we need a
finite sample
um analysis
and another way to think of this finite
Tempo analysis is to think of the
problem of trying to approximate a
graphone convolution with a graph
convolution right you have a graphonius
sample a graph and you apply a
convolution with the same coefficients
on that graph
and so
um this kind of problem this this uh the
essentially the error of that it would
make by making this approximation is
upper bounded by this theorem here
I'm not going to get into all of the
details of the terms in this theorem
um there are some strong topological
assumptions uh which were made kind of
just to show that you know this
decreases within as expected right
because of the graph convolutions
converge but what I want to point out is
that uh
um I would ask you to pay attention to
the to the highlighted terms in this
theorem so this one here on the left
comes from those transferable spectral
components that are far away from zero
the one on the right from those
non-transferable ones close to zero and
what you see by looking at them is that
the transferable the error that you make
coming from the transferable ones
decreases within as expected but you
have this error coming from the
non-transferable ones that doesn't
decrease within right
however this is not too much of a
problem because as uh because C is
typically small and even if it isn't
small as we increase then we can afford
to make that threshold smaller because
we have convergence of those small
eigenvalues as we increase in
um however and this is good because then
it means that we can kind of have
filters that discriminate eigenvalues
closer to zero but the problem is that
if we want filters that are more
discriminative discriminative we need a
larger lipsticks constant ah and that
increases the transferability error so
here again we see that
um that trade-off arise right
how much time do I have
okay so I'm gonna speed up some of these
lives I mean it's not hard to see how
you would go from these approximation
result to a transferability result you
just need to use the triangle inequality
and so for transferability you kind of
have the same trade-off right you have
this kind of incompatibility in these
linear models between uh transferability
and and spectral discriminability
um and this kind of causes these these
differences in amplification that kind
of add up and lead to a larger
transferability error
so finally I get to graph neural
networks and it's a little bit weird
right in a talk that I wanted to talk
about
um graph neural networks I'm going to
send so little time talking about them
but there's a good reason for that and
the reason for that is that um
um graph neural networks in terms of
architecture they're only a minor
um uh
they're only
they only have a minor difference with
respect to graph convolutions
which is that they're actually composed
of these Cascade of layers
each one of uh which is composed of a
graph convolution followed by a point
rise molinearity for example the relu
the sigmoid which is node wise on the
graph
and similarly we can define a graphone
neural network
as this uh layered architecture where
each layer consists of a graphone
convolution followed by a point-wise
nonlinearity and so because uh you know
these gnns and graphoinins are such
minor modifications of graph and
graphene convolutions but we could
expect is then that they would inherit
the convolutions transferability
properties right and this theorem kind
of shows that they do
because the only difference in that
approximation bound now is a dependence
on the number of layers and the number
of features per layer of the GNN but
everything else is the same
but what is interesting is that you know
we have seen in practice that gnns are
more transferable so that there must be
something uh else that's going on here
and so our hypothesis is that even
though non-linearities are such a minor
change in architecture they're actually
pretty important when it comes to their
spectral effect
because what they do is they
they have this effect of scattering
spectral components over the eigenvalue
Spectrum right and so in doing so we can
expect that some of those factorial
components um associated with egregates
close to Lambda equal to zero end up
being scattered to end of the spectrum
where then the filters in the next layer
of the GNN are able to discriminate them
and so that would explain why for the
same level of discriminability gnns are
more transferable than graph filters and
vice versa right
and so uh I'm a literature on time so I
just want to conclude by by going back
to those those two numerical examples
where we had indeed seen that GN the
gnns which are here in orange and green
uh for the same kind of size of the
training graph they achieve a lower
transference error than the graph filter
and I don't have the numbers here but
these graph filters and gnns have a very
similar performance on the test set and
this is the case in both of these um
in both of these problems and even more
so the case when we penalize the GNN to
have a low filters with low lip sheets
constant we just add a penalty which is
the largest uh which is constant of the
filters in the layers of the Genet
so uh with that I would like to conclude
I just wanted to say that you know we
had observed that gnns were more
transferable than graph convolutional
filters um empirically
um
and that seemed to imply that uh you
know gnns are better than graph filters
but we didn't really know why at first
and then when we went on to study
convergence and transferability uh it
looked like you know there's this
incompatibility between transferability
and discriminability but as it turns out
because of the non-linear the mixing
properties of non-linearities gnn's um
that appears to explain why gnns are
more transferable than graph filters in
practice and kind of provide some
evidence to support using gnns for doing
machine learning on large scale graphs
thank you very much
thanks Lana for the interesting talk
questions oh
yeah
so so you wanted to mention what you do
when you have this temporal this Dynamic
network is just instead of the adjacency
Matrix you work with higher dimensional
tensors like a three three-dimensional
tensor in that case I suppose
and if you have multiple channels I
guess it'll just increase the dimension
of the tensors is that right
you would have like
t s plus one
okay so you have communication delays
and also same with X right x t because
the the the signal here is the agent
stage so it's position velocity that's
also changing over time so it would also
be in the expected
thanks for the lovely talk so um in the
sparse case I guess the differences
between the adjacency Matrix and some
related linear operators matter more
than they do in the dense case so one
person mentioned the laplacian I guess
and you can also Imagine in the case
where there's a lot of inhomogeneity in
the degrees that it's sometimes for some
applications it seems more suitable to
use the degree normalized adjacency
Matrix a bit more like
you know so I guess the difference is
when I gossip do I broadcast to all of
my neighbors at uh at unit cost or does
it cost me more to talk to more
neighbors and I was also wondering if in
the sparse case you could do something
like this with the non-backtracking
Matrix one of my favorite matrices
because because in the recommendation
case you might want to avoid an echo
chamber where I tell you I like
something that makes you like it that
makes me like it more that makes you
like it more and that kind of silly
thing and the non-backtracking Matrix
avoids that and brings in fresh
information from elsewhere so I guess do
you think that there's an analogous uh
theory that works for sparse graphs that
are uh have a fair amount of degree in
homogeneity and or you know you use a
totally different set of limits Graphics
or whatever to make that fly yeah I I
mean I'm also very I don't know the
answer to that question I'm very
interested in that question as well so I
I guess one thing one interesting thing
to point out is that for example in the
flocking example those graphs are not
then scraps they're not the reference
not the best model but even there You
observe some of those You observe those
trade-offs You observe those behaviors
and so there's some empirical evidence
to suggest that you have similar results
there but it's something that I'm very
interested in as well
um hoping to find out more about here
okay if there are no questions thank you
[Applause]
thank you